[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers
guten Abend den allen im Machtapparat
des Iran fürchten sie die Revolution auf
den Straßen des Landes rufen Sie nach
der Revolution
zweieinhalb Monate lang dauern die
Proteste bereits zweieinhalb Monate in
denen die Regierung hart durchgreift und
sich gleichzeitig mit allen Mitteln
darum bemüht dass die Welt von all dem
möglichst nichts erfährt die
Demonstranten haben jetzt zu drei Tagen
Generalstreik aufgerufen die Justiz
kündigt an die berüchtigte Sittenpolizei
werde aufgelöst zeigt das wie sehr der
Druck steigt oder versuchen die
Machthaber einen Ablenkungsmanöver Jörg
Brase mit mir
sie kommen in kleinen Bussen einige
uniformierte Frauen im Tschador nehmen
die die sich nicht genau an die
Kleidervorschriften halten mit
iransitten Polizei setzt die Kopftuch
Regeln oft mit brutaler Härte durch
seit Mitte der 80er Jahre gibt es die
Moralwächter die zuletzt im
Innenministerium unterstellt waren sie
sollen Frauen im richtigen Tragen des
Hijab unterweisen doch seit dem Tod
Masse aminis die nach einem Einsatz der
Sittenwächter starb ist die
Polizeitruppe erneut umstritten nun soll
sich ihre ans Generalstaatsanwalt
indirekt zu deren Auflösung geäußert
haben die Sittenpolizei hat nichts mit
der Judikative zu tun sondern sie wurde
von der Stelle die Sie eingerichtet hat
abgeschafft
eine offizielle Bestätigung der
Auflösung der Sittenpolizei durch das
Innenministerium gibt es nicht angeblich
so montesserie soll auch über eine
Reform der kopftuchregeln diskutiert
werden eine Diskussion die es ebenfalls
seit einiger Zeit im iranischen
Parlament gibt in Heidelberg es ist
unwahrscheinlich dass das Kopftuch
komplett abgeschafft wird aber es könnte
Änderungen geben wie mit dem Kopftuch
Gebot umgegangen wird
meinte irans Präsident Reis sie genau
das gestern auf einer Pressekonferenz in
Teheran die iranische Verfassung sei gut
und richtig meinte er aber die Methoden
um unsere Gesetze umzusetzen können
überprüft werden nicht aber die Werte
die den Gesetzen zugrunde liegen die
Methoden können wir ändern nicht aber
die Werte
wir konnten heute mit einigen iranischen
Frauen reden vor der Kamera wollten sie
sich nicht äußern dass eine mögliche
Abschaffung der Sittenpolizei
irgendetwas ändern würde glauben Sie
nicht
die Sittenpolizei zu schließen hat für
mich keine Bedeutung das Kopftuch macht
nur ein Zehntel der Probleme aus mit
denen wir zu kämpfen haben das ist nur
ein Trick mit dem Sie uns ruhig stellen
wollen und eine andere Frau sagt sie
glauben sie könnten uns damit beruhigen
aber das ist falsch das ist alles nur
ein böses Spiel unser Ziel ist eine
Revolution ist die Islamische Republik
sie wollen weitermachen ab morgen wurde
zu neuen dreitägigen Protesten und
Streiks im ganzen Land aufgerufen
da fangen wir nochmal nach bei Jörg
Brase unserem Korrespondenten für den
Iran jetzt sind Istanbul Jörg guten
Abend Auflösung der Sittenpolizei wir
haben schon gelernt der ist sehr sehr
viel Skepsis bei den Menschen im Iran
ist das jetzt Kosmetik
enttäuschungsmanöver oder zeigt es
einfach wieder wie sehr das Regime
tatsächlich unter Druck steht
also ich denke mir ist wahrscheinlich
von allem ein bisschen der iranische
Generalstaatsanwalt hatte er angekündigt
dass die iranische Justiz auf jeden Fall
weiter dafür sorgen will dass die
islamischen Kleidervorschriften
umgesetzt werden das heißt man ähm und
durchgesetzt werden das heißt man muss
jetzt erstmal sehen ob diese
Patrouille in der Sittenpolizei
tatsächlich aus dem Straßenbild
verschwinden oder ob jetzt andere
Behörden diese Aufgaben übernehmen das
Kopftuch Gebot durchsetzen und wenn ja
wie ihre groß die das tun was er
ebenfalls gesagt hat ist das ist in den
nächsten Tagen
Diskussionen im iranischen Parlament
geben soll und zwar zum Thema Kopftuch
Pflicht das klingt jetzt danach als ob
es da Reformen geben könnte auch das
wäre jetzt nichts Neues auch das ist
schon seit vielen Wochen diskutiert
worden aber dass das Kopftuch komplett
fällt in der Islamischen Republik das
halte ich für relativ unmöglich oder das
wird sicherlich nicht passieren die
Regierung aber steht unter Druck es gab
heute in Krisen Treffen von Präsident
reisi mit seinen Ministern wo man über
die Lage diskutieren wollte was dabei
genau herausgekommen ist dass wurde
bisher noch nicht bekannt gegeben es ist
ja Jörg generell schwer unabhängig zu
verifizieren was da genau im Land
passiert die horror-meldungen auf jeden
Fall häufen sich was lässt sich denn
sagen über die Lage der mutigen
Demonstranten und Demonstranten
also ich fürchte an deren Lage wird sich
nicht viel ändern die Regierung hat
angekündigt dass sie Gesprächsangebote
machen will dass sie Diskussionsforen
gründen will und mit dem protestieren
ins Gespräch zu kommen die aber haben
zumindest die die auf die Straße gehen
überhaupt keine Interesse an solchen
Gesprächen sie fordern weiter eine Sturz
des Regimes ich denke dass die Mehrheit
der Bevölkerung auch tatsächlich die
Unzufriedenheit der der die auf die
Straße gehen teilt dass sie auch
vielleicht den Willen zum Wechsel teilen
aber sie trauen sich eben noch nicht auf
die Straße und wie sich das jetzt
entwickelt das muss man in den nächsten
Tagen sehen ob positionsgruppen hatten
ja so dreitägigen Demonstrationen
aufgerufen jetzt muss man mal sehen ob
die Zahl derer die auf die Straße gehen
wächst oder ob die Zuckerbrot und
Peitsche Politik der Regierung wird
herzlichen Dank für diese Analyse vielen
Dank
nach der sehr frühen Abreise der
deutschen Nationalmannschaft aus Katar
gibt es einiges aufzuarbeiten im Fußball
sowieso aber darum geht es jetzt nicht
die lokalen Fans vor Ort haben den
Deutschen eher schadenfroh hinterher
gewunken die WM ist für sie längst zu
einer Feier der arabischen Welt geworden
auf die sie stolz sind das größte
Fußballfest der Erde zum ersten Mal in
ihrer Region
Kata wird nach dieser WM einer der
größten Energielieferanten der Erde
bleiben es bleibt größter arabischer
Investor in Deutschland es bleibt ein
Land mit hochproblematischer
Menschenrechtslage über all das wird
weiter zu sprechen sein wie Deutschland
das allerdings tut darüber läuft jetzt
eine Debatte der deutsche Botschafter in
Katar warnt mit drastischen Worten vor
einem zerrütteten Verhältnis aus Doha
gollineartei
Doha ein Traum der an das Klischee von
1000 und einer Nacht erinnert
Spektakel und Wunderland majestätisch
[Musik]
unbeschwert
Frauen schauen Mode an mit der die Golf
Araberin zur Königin der Nacht wird
die Fassaden wie in Paris oder Mailand
aber die festliche Stimmung ist
plötzlich vorbei wenn man hier nach
Deutschland und den deutschen fragt die
einstigen fußballlieblinge Arabiens
viele Araber waren froh als die
Deutschen aus der WM flogen
wir waren die größten Fans der deutschen
aber diese Geste hat uns offen gesagt
schockiert
ich darf nichts dazu sagen diese Geste
der deutschen die schadete mehr Ihnen
als uns
Sport und Häme Katars
fernsehkommentatoren verabschiedeten
sich mit einem unterdrückten Lachen von
den deutschen
Katara tauchten beim Deutschlandspiel
mit Bildern des Ex-Nationalspielers
Mesut Özil auf als Beleg für deutsche
Doppelstandards auf die Armbinde der
deutschen Innenministerin legten mancher
eine propalästinensische Armbinde an
haben die Deutschen sich den Mund
zugehalten bei der WM in Russland
Russland bombardiert syrische Zivilisten
aber da kam nichts von den Deutschen ist
das nicht Heuchelei
man möge ja die Deutschen wirklich sagt
einer der wichtigsten religiösen Stimmen
im Land aber die deutsche
Meinungsdiktatur wie er es nennt die
möge man nicht die könnte gar des
wirtschaftliche und kulturelle Ende
Deutschlands
ist sehr wichtig dass Europa und gerade
Deutschland die Sache mit dem Schutz der
Familie und die Sache mit der
Homosexualität überdenken wenn
Deutschland aber so weitermacht wie
bisher dann fürchte ich dass es sehr
schnell auseinanderbrechen wird
ohne Kater kein warmer Winter in
Deutschland sagt er noch vergessen sie
das nicht
tatsächlich hatte Kattas Energieminister
gerade erst Gas für Deutschland
versprochen nicht ohne einen Seitenhieb
auf die deutschen während die alles
vermischten könne eher Politik und
Geschäft voneinander trennen
in Doha ist spürbar die Beziehung zu
einem wichtigen westlichen Verbündeten
hat Schaden genommen deutsche
Wirtschaftsvertreter sind in Sorge
Deutschlands Botschafter warnt das
Auswärtige Amt
der Vertrauensbonus ist in den letzten
Wochen verloren gegangen die aktuelle
Stimmung gegenüber Deutschland in
hiesigen Wirtschaftskreisen wird mehr
als miserabel geschildert
was tun die kathara warteten auf eine
deutsche Würdigung ihrer WM heißt es
sprich weniger Deutsche Werte mehr
deutsche Interessen im Umgang mit Doha
ja wenn wir uns das so anschauen will
ist eins klar was Deutschland sagt und
tut wird beachtet das heißt aber eben
auch Deutschland muss genauer überlegen
wie es wichtiger Anliegen erfolgreich
vertritt kritisch und klar aber eben
ohne simple Symbolpolitik und wohlfeile
Social Media Empörung die morgen alle
vergessen haben
die Nachrichtenübersicht jetzt hast du
Hannah ja mit dem Ziel die deutsche
Wirtschaft klimafreundlicher zu
gestalten ist Wirtschafts- und
klimaminister Harbeck heute nach Namibia
gereist bei den Gesprächen dort soll es
um grünen Wasserstoff gehen den Namibia
künftig nach Deutschland liefern könnte
so die Hoffnung der Bundesregierung am
Montagabend geht es für Haarwerk dann
weiter nach Südafrika dort sollen unter
anderem auf einer deutsch-afrikanischen
Konferenz die Wirtschaftsbeziehungen
vertieft werden
deshalb vador will der
Bandenkriminalität ein Ende setzen dazu
sollen komplette Städte abgeriegelt
werden so wie aktuell soll ja pango das
von 10.000 Soldaten und Polizisten
umgestellt wurde systematisch durch
Kempten Einsatzkräfte Straßen und Häuser
auf der Suche nach Bandenmitgliedern
mehr als 56.000 Personen wurden in den
letzten Monaten festgenommen seit März
herrscht Ausnahmezustand in dem
zentralamerikanischen Land damals waren
innerhalb weniger Tage fast 90 Menschen
ermordet worden
eu-kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen
hat einen Kurswechsel bei der
Investitionspolitik in Europa gefordert
um Wettbewerbsnachteile gegenüber den
USA abzufedern müssten die
EU-Vorschriften für öffentliche
Investitionen gelockert werden zudem
brauche es zusätzliche Finanzmittel zur
Förderung sauberer Technologien
hintergrund ist ein Streit zwischen
Europa und den USA und milliardenschwere
us-subventionen für den Klimaschutz mit
denen ausschließlich Produkte made in
USA gefördert werden sollen die
EU-Staaten fürchten dadurch eine
Benachteiligung europäischer Unternehmen
die Mitbegründerin der russischen
Menschenrechtsorganisation Memorial
Irina scherbakova ist mit dem Marion
dönhoff-preis für internationale
Verständigung und Versöhnung
ausgezeichnet worden die Tafel
Deutschland bekam den Förderpreis
Bundeskanzler Scholz würde ich der
scherbakova bei der Verleihung in
Hamburg als Seelenverwandte und
Mitstreiterinnen im Kampf für eine
friedliche und demokratische Zukunft
Europas ihre Organisation Memorial wurde
in diesem Jahr bereits mit dem
Friedensnobelpreis ausgezeichnet
was ist recht ohne ein unabhängiges
Gericht das dieses durchsetzt nichts was
ist Europa ohne seinen Gerichtshof so
gesehen ebenfalls nicht vorstellbar der
EuGH wir in der juristischen
Leidenschaft für Abkürzungen heißt wird
heute 70 Jahre alt 70 Jahre in denen
eine Institution entstand die
europäisches Recht hoch hält und dabei
zusehends kollidiert mit denen die im
vorwerfen seine Kompetenzen zu
übertreten und denen die sich ganz
generell von gemeinsamen Rechtsnormen in
Europa entfernen wollen und die
Richterinnen und Richter in Luxemburg
dabei nur stören
es steht viel auf dem Spiel ein
unbeschwerter Geburtstag ist das nicht
ich spreche hier gleich mit dem
Präsidenten des EuGH erst stellt Sarah
Tacke Europas höchstes Gericht vor
hier im kleinen Luxemburg ist der groß
geworden riesig mächtig einflussreich
denn seine Entscheidung wirken sich
direkt auf 450 Millionen Menschen aus
verändern auch das Leben jedes deutschen
so haben Sie hier unter anderem
entschieden unter welchen Umständen ein
Arbeitgeber das Tragen eines Kopftuchs
verbieten darf und auch bestimmt dass es
in Deutschland keine Pkw-Maut geben wird
und sogar vorgegeben was Online-Käufer
bei der Rückgabe einer Matratze beachten
müssen das Gericht versteht sich auch
und vor allem als Anwalt der Bürgerinnen
und Bürger
der Europäische Gerichtshof hat in den
letzten 70 Jahren eine ganz bedeutende
Stellung erreicht er hat durch seine
eigene Rechtsprechung festgelegt dass
das Recht der Europäischen Union dem
Recht der Mitgliedstaaten vorgeht und
weil das Recht der Europäischen Union
inzwischen praktisch alle Rechtsbereiche
erfasst hat er in all diesen
Rechtsbereichen das letzte Wort
doch genau an diesem Grundsatz dass der
Europäische Gerichtshof in allen
Rechtsbereichen das letzte Wort hat wird
aktuell kräftig gerüttelt ein Anschluss
dafür kam aus Deutschland denn das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat sich vor
zwei Jahren in seiner EZB Entscheidung
über den Europäischen Gerichtshof
hinweggesetzt
indem der Gerichtshof hier seiner
Kontrollaufgabe nicht nachkommt handelt
er ultravirus
ultravirus die attestierte
Kompetenzüberschreitung
härter hätte ein Gericht die Arbeit von
Kollegen kaum kritisieren können
15 16 das ist für Luxemburg eine große
Herausforderung weil das eigentlich die
Grundfeste des Rechts der Rechtsprechung
des Europäischen Gerichtshofs ist dass
das europäische Recht vorgeht dem
nationalen Recht auch dem nationalen
Verfassungsrecht
der Streit schwitzt sich vor einem Jahr
noch zu als der polnische
Verfassungsgerichtshof sogar den Vorrang
des EU-Rechts generell in Frage stellt
die EU-Organe überschreiten ihre
Kompetenzen und die polnische Republik
kann nicht demokratisch und souverän
agieren
mit dieser Entscheidung greift Polen die
Autorität des Gerichts direkt an das
kann der Europäische Gerichtshof aber
nicht hinnehmen weil sonst die
Europäische Union keine
Rechtsgemeinschaft mehr ist
es steht also viel auf dem Spiel 70
Jahre nach Gründung des Europäischen
Gerichtshofs
[Musik]
ist der Präsident des Europäischen
Gerichtshofs einer der auch das Leben
von uns allen hier in Deutschland
verändert herr Präsident schön dass Sie
da sind ich freue mich sehr dass sie am
Geburtstag ihrer Institution den Weg aus
Luxemburg hier nach Mainz gefunden haben
herzlichen Dank für die Einladung
herr Präsident 42.000 Entscheidungen hat
der EuGH getroffen in den letzten 70
Jahren auf welche sind Sie besonders
stolz
ich bin besonders stolz auf die Urteile
die den Anwendungsvorrang des
Unionsrechts die direktwirkung des
Unionsrechts und auch die
Rechtsstaatlichkeit in den
Mitgliedstaaten betont haben okay
darüber werden wir gleich noch ein
bisschen reden über die Probleme auch
die mit der Rechtsstaatlichkeit
mancherorts gibt das heißt alles was Sie
gerade gesagt haben da geraten sie
natürlich auch in Konflikt mit
nationalen Gerichten mit nationalen
Regierungen sie haben einiges an Macht
haben Sie auch gerne das letzte Wort
die Frage des letzten Wortes ist keine
gute Frage
in
Unionsrecht geht es darum das gemeinsame
vorzusprechen man darf nie vergessen
dass das Unionsrecht eine gemeinsame
Rechtsordnung darstellt für 27
Mitgliedstaaten damit es gemeinsames
recht bleibt braucht man auch ein
gemeinsames Gericht und das haben die
Mitgliedstaaten sehr gut verstanden wenn
sie und niemand anderes den EuGH
geschaffen hat aber nun sind nicht alle
immer gemeinsam derselben Meinung
manchmal muss man auch gemacht Wort
sprechen macht ist nicht das Gute Wort
für eine gerätbarkeit man spricht
eigentlich das Recht man
Rechtsprechung man spricht das Recht und
für die Union man spricht ein
gemeinsames Recht das Unionsrecht muss
einheitlich ausgelegt
und angewendet werden damit es
gemeinsames recht bleibt und alle
Mitgliedstaaten und deren Bürgerinnen
und Bürger gleich für das Unionsrecht
bleiben Frage noch mal andersrum was
würde passieren wenn es den EuGH nicht
gäbe
dann hätte es auch nicht 70 Jahre
Europäische Union gegeben ohne eine
gemeinsame Gerichtsbarkeit kann keine
gemeinsame Rechtsordnung nachhaltig am
Leben bleiben jetzt ist es aber so dass
sogar ihre Kolleginnen und Kollegen sage
ich jetzt mal in Karlsruhe also sprich
die höchsten nationalen Richter hier bei
uns in Deutschland am
Bundesverfassungsgericht auch schon mal
klar gemacht haben moment mal ihr Europa
Richter ihr geht dazu weit in euren
Kompetenzen was können sie denn besser
als ein nationales Gericht wie das in
Karlsruhe
das ist nicht eine Frage von wer kann
das besser
jedes Gericht hat seine eigene Aufgabe
die Aufgabe des OGH dessen jahrestages
70 jahrestages wir heute feiern ist das
gemeinsame recht auszulegen
wir schauen
aus der Sicht von Europa insgesamt ein
nationales Verfassungsgericht ist
beschränkt auf die nationale
Verfassungslage und das ist nicht so nur
für das Bundesverfassungsgericht das ist
so für die verfassungs-
das ist ihre klare Ansage dazu das haben
sie auch Richtung Warschau zum Beispiel
unmissverständlich klar gemacht jetzt
kommt aber aus Polen zum Beispiel zurück
das ist uns egal wir sagen eben unser
nationales Recht geht vor Europa Recht
hat nicht mehr automatisch Vorrang und
wir anerkennen quasi ihre
richtsgerichtssprüche ihr recht was sie
setzen nicht mehr an was sagen Sie dazu
das muss doch lebensgefährlich sein für
so einen gerichtshofieren oder
lebensgefährlich ist das zum Glück nicht
ich kann ihnen sicheren das was das
polnische Gerichtshof
Verfassungsgerichtshof gesagt hat eilig
mit dem Vorrang des Unionsrechts nicht
zu tun hat es hat sich ausgesprochen
über unsere Rechtsprechung über die
Unabhängigkeit
der polnischen Gerichtsbarkeit
damit hat es zu tun dass sie andere
Ansicht sind über die
rechtsstaatlichkeitsfrage und
insbesondere über die
unabhängigkeitsfragen der polnischen
Gerichte andere Ansicht als der
europäische Gerichtshof
der eine gemeinsame Auffassung für alle
Mitgliedstaaten ausgesprochen hat jetzt
haben sie aber zum Beispiel auch ein
Zwangsgeld festgesetzt gegen Polen eine
Million Euro jeden Tag ist das der
richtige Weg um auch zu zeigen Freunde
wir lassen uns nicht auf der Nase
herumtanzen in Europa ja
dieses Schwein Geld ist von
Vizepräsidenten des Orgas über
auferlegt um eine einstweilige Anordnung
zu achten und das ist eigentlich ein
normaler Verfahrensweg der auch in
anderen Bereichen
geformt werden kann das ist es
eigentlich und das ist auch wichtig weil
sonst macht eine Gerichtsentscheidung
keinen Sinn wenn sie am Ende ohne
Sanktionen bleibt oder
herr Präsident ich würde gerne noch zum
Schluss Fragen 70 Geburtstag schauen wir
einen Moment nach vorne wie bleibt man
oberstes Gericht und lässt gleichzeitig
den Mitgliedsstaaten auch noch Raum für
eigene Entscheidungen was wäre ihr
Fahrplan ihr Motto für die nächsten 70
Jahre mein Motto ist dass die Union in
die in der Vielfalt geeint ist und es
ist die größte Herausforderung für
unseren Gerichtshof um sicher zu stellen
dass die Einheitlichkeit der
auslegen und Anwendung des Unionsrechts
den Mitgliedstaaten alle Spielraum für
eigene Identität überlässt die absolut
mit der Einheitlichkeit des Unionsrechts
vereinbar sind dort haben wir die
Aufgabe wie das oberste Gerichts
in den Vereinigten Staaten um die
Abwägung zu machen zwischen Einheit und
Vielfalt und das ist Aufgabe eines
gemeinsamen Gerichts für 27
Mitgliedstaaten zwischen Einheit und
Vielfalt der Präsident des Europäischen
Gerichtshofes ganz herzlichen Dank dass
Sie bei uns waren der Präsident danke
apropos Vielfalt in den Türmen des
Europäischen Gerichtshofs sitzen unter
den mehr als 2000 Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeitern viele die überhaupt erstmal
über übersetzen damit Justitia
verstanden wird 24 Amtssprachen das
heißt das Gericht hat in der Praxis zu
tun mit insgesamt
Sprachkombinationen das Gespräch haben
wir aus Termin Gründen heute Mittag
aufgezeichnet und jetzt noch mal Johanna
der indonesischen Insel Java ist der
Vulkan semero ausgebrochen genau ein
Jahr nach der letzten Eruption seit den
frühen Morgenstunden stößt der Vulkan
Asche heißes Gas und Lava aus die
Behörden riefen die höchste Warnstufe
aus fast 2000 Menschen mussten sich
bisher in Sicherheit bringen der
Inselstaat Indonesien befindet sich auf
dem Pazifischen Feuerring der geologisch
aktivsten Zone der Erde
und jetzt der sportliche Blick zur
Fußball-WM in Katar dort hat Frankreich
heute einen weiteren Schritt Richtung
Titelverteidigung gemacht nach einem
3:1-erfolg gegen Polen am frühen Abend
stehen die Franzosen im Viertelfinale
auch dank Superstar mbappé der an allen
Treffern seiner Mannschaft beteiligt war
und auch das Spiel England gegen Senegal
ist mittlerweile beendet
siegessichere englische Fans vor dem
Anpfiff aber druckvoller gefährlicher zu
Beginn der Afrika Meister herrlicher
Pass von sah auf dir und Pickford mit
toller Parade er bewahrt den Favoriten
vor dem Rückstand die Briten erst gegen
Ende der ersten Hälfte mit klaren
Offensivaktionen tut Bellingham vom BVB
mit präzise pass auf Henderson 1:0 in
der 39 Minuten
Senegal wirkt jetzt angeschlagen
erneuter Konter der Briten Bellingham
auf Foden dann nimmt Harry Kane Mars das
2:0 kurz vor dem Wechsel
welch Effizienz zwei Chancen zwei Tore
in der zweiten Hälfte diktiert England
weiter das Geschehen fodens path of 3 zu
0 nach 56 Minuten für sacker bereits der
dritte Treffer bei dieser WM 3:0 auf der
Endstand England mit seiner
Favoritenrolle gerecht im Viertelfinale
wird wohl schwieriger da geht es gegen
Titel Verteidiger Frankreich
mal gucken wir jetzt nach vorne wie
immer am Sonntag hier ist der heute
schon mal Ausblick von Erik illenseer
[Musik]
März 2016 Brüssel Terror an der Stadt
islamistische selbstmordatentäter zünden
Bomben am Flughafen und in der U-Bahn am
Montag wird der Prozess beginnen die
Geschworenen sind bereits ausgewählt
angeklagt sind zehn Männer sie sollen
beteiligt gewesen sein
eine Generalüberholung für das
Gesundheitssystem am Dienstag in Berlin
will Bundesminister Lauterbach die
geplanten Neuerungen erklären gemeinsam
mit der sogenannten Regierungskommission
Krankenhausversorgung wo braucht es wie
viele Kliniken der übernimmt die Planung
wie läuft die Finanzierung
dem Artensterben Einhalt gebieten ein
Ziel das angesichts des fortschreitenden
Klimawandels schwer erreichbar scheint
die 15 un
biodiversitätskonferenz in Montreal will
es erreichen und ein Abkommen
beschließen mit ihm würden 30% der land-
und Meeresfläche und der Schutz gestellt
Alarmstufe Rot am Donnerstag dem zweiten
bundesweiten warntag es ist ein neuer
großer Testlauf für die alarmstrukturen
im Land nach dem pannengeplagten ersten
Versuch vor gut zwei Jahren erstmals
wird auch die Warnung per SMS
großflächig getestet
und jetzt noch ein weiterer Ausblick und
zwar aufs Wetter morgen bleibt es vom
Rhein-Main-Gebiet bis in die Lausitz
meist trocken sonst regnet es in den
Bergen schneit es häufig im Norden liegt
die Schneefallgrenze bei 300 im Süden
bei 700 Metern die Temperatur steigt auf
Wert davon ein bis sieben Grad in den
nächsten Tagen gibt es vor allem im
Norden Regen und Schneeschauer die
Höchsttemperatur liegt bei 0 bis 6 Grad
im Namen vom gesamten Team auch dem
hinter den Kameras danke dass Sie bei
uns waren danke für Ihr Interesse und
noch dieser Hinweis morgen freuen sich
hier Maria taslonka und Hans Wolf auf
Sie und wir wünschen Ihnen noch einen
angenehmen Abend
[Musik]